je vous parlais de la manière dont un
reportage a considérablement changé
toute ma vie alors pourtant c'est un
portage comme vous en avez sûrement vu
on en a tous vu les comme ça ça parle de
guerre sa part des victimes
ça parle de traumatisme mais moi ce
moment là il ya quelque chose qui s'est
déclenché alors peut-être parce que
j'avais 23 ans j'étais étudiante en
psychologie
j'étais peut-être plus sensibles à ça
mais dans ce reportage
il y avait une petite fille une petite
pique qui présentait des tic savez les
tics ses petits mouvements convulsifs
que vous pouvez pas maîtrisé elle
présentait des tic au niveau des yeux
dans son reportage elle était filmée
dans son école à alep et elle était
collée à son enseignant en clignant des
yeux tellement souvent qu'elle pouvait
presque plus voir le monde qui
l'entourait à ce moment là ça fait tilt
cette petite fille elle m'a marqué parce
qu'elle m'a vraiment fait permis de
prendre conscience de tous les troubles
nerveux qui peuvent arriver
suite à une menace de mort elle m'a
vraiment fait comprendre ce que c'était
que le trouble de stress post
traumatique le trouble de stress post
traumatique
c'est quelque chose qui peut vous
arriver suite à une menace de mort et
vous allez développer des symptômes sur
le long cours alors ça va être d un
sentiment d'insécurité
ça va être un sentiment danger permanent
vous allez faire des cauchemars la nuit
vous allez être complètement envahie le
trouble de stress post traumatique ça
peut aussi vous apporter des affects
dépressif vous sentirez forcément moins
bien ça peut vous apporter de l'anxiété
alors vous êtes vivant vous avez survécu
mais à l'intérieur vous est détruit et
là il fallait faire quelque chose pour
travailler sur le trouble de stress post
traumatique forcément travailler sur ses
pensées
mais c'est pas si facile de travailler
sur ses pensées on va essayer de
maîtriser vos pensées des fois ça marche
bien bon alors on va essayer de faire un
petit exercice tous ensemble je vais
vous demander de fermer les yeux si je
les ai fermé les yeux et je vais vous
demander d'imaginer un ours polaire
vous allez répondre aux questions je
vais vous poser dans vos têtes
sinon ça va être un peu compliqué à
comprendre alors cet ours polaires vous
l'avez dans vos têtes
est-ce qu'il est grand est ce qu'il est
petit
vous le voyez de loin de près au profil
de trois quarts il a la gueule ouverte
fermé hier plutôt gentil plutôt menaçant
bon ok c'est vrai on pouvait rire les
yeux maintenant vous avez le droit de
penser à ce que vous voulez sauf un ours
polaire et vous levez la main quand vous
avez perdu
ah oui quand même
voyez à quel point c'est difficile de
travailler sur ses pensées de maîtriser
ses pensées c'est à partir de là que je
me suis engagé j'ai commencé à être
bénévole dans une association
humanitaire qui intervenaient en syrie
en apportant en aidant en tout cas
acheminer du matériel médical en aidant
à acheminer des colis alimentaires à
parrainer des enfants qui est orphelin
ensuite je suis devenu stagiaires et
puis j'ai fini chef de projet
humanitaire et à ce moment là ce qu'on
m'a demandé c'est est de concevoir un
nouveau projet assez intuitivement j'ai
pensé à créer une école qu elle est
regroupée sur la même place un centre de
soutien psychologique
on allait avoir l'aspect pédagogique été
créés en charge et l'aspect
psychologique
les deux est encensé s'entraider et ça
vu le jour on avait des résultats on a
mis en place plein de choses au niveau
thérapeutique
on a fait de l'art thérapie on a fait la
thérapie d'exposition mais on sentait
qu'il y avait quand même quelque chose
de possible
on sentait qu'il y avait quelque chose
qu'on pouvait encore améliorée des
résultats qu'on allait devoir aller
chercher plus loin
alors je me suis renseigné j'ai regardé
ce qu'il y avait dans la littérature
je suis tombé sur les travaux du
professeur houssin ménages qui est
professeur universitaire ici à tour et
de son collègue le professeur alain
dominé qui est lui chercheur au canada
en psychologie
ezio miron au point une thérapie courte
qu'on n'a pas été rapide
potentialisation alors en fait c'est
tout simple vous avez votre passion vous
allez reprendre avec lui son récit
traumatique c'est à dire vous allez
reprendre et vous allez écrire le
traumatisme qu'il a vécu et puis vous
allez l'exposer à son propre récit
traumatique et vous allez ajouter avec
cette thérapie d'exposition un
médicament s'appelle le propranolol
c'est un bêtabloquant donc c'est un
médicament qui stoppe les réactions du
stress et qui sont censées quand vous
allez relire votre récit traumatique
distinguer la charge émotionnelle
souvenirs et donc vous pouvez baisser
les symptômes ce protocole on l'appliqué
dans le cadre d'une association que j'ai
créé sa peine dans la génération qui a
été fondée au nord de la syrie à
l'intérieur du territoire au sein d'un
camp de réfugiés
tous ces enfants font partie 2 158
enfants fréquentent le centre
tous les jours et 121 de ces enfants
sont passés dans le protocole que je
viens de vous décrire
quand ils sont passés dans ce protocole
et avant de passer aux analyses
statistiques propres à la tout chercheur
on a observé des choses on a pu voir les
enfants qui allait revivre qui allait
sourire qu'ils allaient jouer à nouveau
on a pu voir des enfants qui reprenait
vie qui aller vers les autres qui
s'amusaient qui faisait des bêtises
aussi qu'ils avaient repris leur vie
d'enfant
ce petit garçon envoyé au milieu avant
le protocole on n'aurait pas pu faire
une photo même de haut avec un gros zoom
à l'écart dans une autre pièce c'était
très compliqué et là dans cette photo
vous le voyez il a pris l'initiative
d'organiser un atelier dessin avec
d'autres enfants
c'était l'enfant qui avait le plus de
repli social ensuite on a traité les
données de manière statistique l'a fait
sur tout ce travail de chercheur et les
résultats nous ont aussi parlé on a en
moyenne 40 % d'amélioration de l'état de
santé des enfants sur toutes les
dimensions qu'on a testé l'anxiété la
dépression sur tout ce qui allait être
évitement 40% sur une semaine ça
résultat qui est simplement énorme
alors bien sûr on va aller encore plus
loin on va rechercher encore d'autres
choses on va vouloir trouver des
solutions encore plus efficace on va
essayer de passer par d'autres biais
pour ceux qui vont être résistant mais
ces quelques moments sur lequel j'ai pu
vous exposer un petit peu ce parcours de
vie là aussi un message il message
vraiment que j'avais envie de vous faire
passer c'est de vous dire que s'engager
c'est pas facile
ceux qui vont vous dire qu'on peut que
c'était que c'était vraiment à notre
portée on n'a pas grand chose à faire
c'est faux l'engagement ça demande
énormément de temps d'énergie
ça va ça peut changer radicalement votre
vie comme ça a été le cas pour moi mais
quand même quand on regarde tout ce qui
s'est passé tout ce qu'on a pu faire
je vous assure que ça vaut le coup merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]